a new witcher game is announced
playstation buys a new studio and did i
mention a new witcher game was announced
let's go
cd projekt red has finally announced
that a new game in the witcher series is
in development unlike previous games
development will move from cd projekt's
red engine to unreal engine 5 as part of
a multi-year strategic partnership with
epic games cdpr says that it'll closely
collaborate with epic games developers
to help tailor the engine for open world
experiences at this point further
details on the witchers such as a
development time frame or release date
are currently unavailable we also don't
know if the game will be called witcher
4 or something else while cdpr isn't
ready to share any details about the
next witcher game just yet the company's
chief technology officer did briefly
touch on the company's shifting to
unreal engine 5. and according to epic
game ceo tim sweeney the collaboration
with cdpr will quote push the limits of
interactive storytelling and gameplay
together while also benefiting the
developer community for years to come
cdpr did note that the witcher won't be
an epic game store exclusive indicating
that it will be available on other pc
storefronts as well when it eventually
launches the last witcher game released
was the witcher 3 the wild hunt in 2015
which earned universal acclaim from both
critics and fans selling over 28 million
copies as of april 2020 the game also
had two well-received expansions after
launch with pc sales accounting for over
half of the units bought most recently
cdpr fell short of expectations with
cyberpunk 2077 but have been trying to
earn back player trust following the
game's 1.5 patch the studio is also
still working on expansions for that
game and hopefully it's learned a lot
from that release that can help it
handle the next witcher rollout as
smoothly as it did with the wild hunt
now i can talk your ear off about
everything that i want from a witcher 4
or whatever that this is going to be
titled but
sounds like a topic for another video
i'm not that great at winking instead
let's talk about sony's latest
acquisition sony interactive
entertainment is buying gaming veteran
jade raymond's new studio haven in a
move that comes after the two companies
announced plans to work together on a
new ip a aaa multiplayer experience for
ps5 if you didn't know jade raymond is a
former assassin's creed boss who started
haven after leaving ea and google haven
is staffed by more than 60 people right
now and becomes sony's 18th internal
game studio under the playstation
studio's label this big news comes from
playstation's hermann halst via the
playstation blog today and sony said
quote we are confident in haven's
creative and technical expertise to
deliver on such an ambitious project and
we're thrilled to invest in their
journey developing a new original ip for
playstation in a statement raymond said
haven is also eager to work with and
learn from sie's other first party
studios like gorilla who has multiplayer
experience with killzone naughty dog who
made enjoyable multiplayer for uncharted
and last of us as well as media molecule
and insomniac games all studios with
incredible strengths that haven can
learn so much from switching gears to a
little gaming on the go steam deck
already supports tons of games but now
you can add xbox's cloud gaming service
to that list microsoft says it worked
closely with valve to enable cloud
gaming support which is now available
through microsoft's edge browser in beta
the new addition means that any game
that runs through xbox's cloud service
can now be played on the handheld system
from valve microsoft put out detailed
instructions on how to get edge up and
running on steam deck how to switch the
controller layout to recognize the
gamepad and even a piece of custom
artwork you can use to set up as a
shortcut this is how game pass
eventually came to ios devices through a
shortcut button made by a safari browser
but keep in mind that since you're
tinkering with linux command lines to
change permissions if you do something
wrong you may need to factory reset but
alright i'm throwing a witcher 4 party
right now so get over here i got a bag
of nerds each one of you gets a nerd and
a capri sun and we're going to live it
up all right
i'll see you tomorrow
[Music]